BRET?
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
GRIFF, THANK YOU.
MEANTIME, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TRYING TO BOLSTER HIS CLIMATE
CHANGE CREDENTIALS WITH UPSET
PROGRESSIVES TONIGHT.
THIS COMES AS SOME FROM HIS OWN
BASE ARE CALLING THE PRESIDENT A
COWARD.
TODAY, PRESIDENT BIDEN TRIED TO
EQUATE GLOBAL WARMING WITH THE
WESTERN HEAT WAVE.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY HAS DETAILS.
>> Peter: SAYS IT'S SIMPLE.
>> I HOPE YOU KNOW AND IT
CONSTITUENTS KNOW IT THERE IS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
[CHANTING]
>> Peter: BECAUSE MEANINGFUL
CLIMATE ACTION WAS CUT OUT OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FRAMEWORK
ACTIVISTS ARE FURIOUS.
MARCHING AS CLOSE TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AS THEY COULD WITH SIGNS
READING, QUOTE:  BIDEN, YOU
COWARD.
FIGHT FOR US.
>> SOMETIMES NEED A REMINDER OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT TOOK THEM
TO THE DANCE, RIGHT?
WE ARE INVITING THE WHITE HOUSE
TO A DANCE.
>> MESSAGE RECEIVED IN THE WEST
WING.
>> I WOULD SAY FIRST THAT WE
RESPECT THE RIGHT OF ANYONE TO
PEACEFULLY PROTEST.
THAT'S AN AMERICAN RIGHT AND
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
I WILL SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES THAT WHAT'S IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE IS AN
IMPORTANT DOWN PAYMENT ON
ADDRESSING WHAT HE SEES AS A
CRISIS IN OUR CLIMATE.
>> Peter: ON A ZOOM CALL WITH
WESTERN GOVERNORS,
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS TRIED
TO HIGHLIGHT A HEIGHTENED RISK
OF WILDFIRES THIS SEASON WITH
THE VICE PRESIDENT DRAWING UPON
HER EXPERIENCE IN PARADISE,
CALIFORNIA.
>> THE ONLY THING STANDING IN
THAT COMMUNITY WERE THE
CHIMNEYS, WHICH LOOK IN THAT
SCENE LIKE TOMBSTONES.
>> Peter: THE COLLAPSED CONDO IN
FLORIDA COULD HAVE BEEN CAUSED
BY CLIMATE CHANGE, TOO ACCORDING
TO THE ENERGY SECRETARY JENNIFER
GRANHOLM.
>> WE DO KNOW THAT THE SEAS ARE
RISING.
I MEAN, WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
LOSING INCHES AND INCHES OF
BEACHES.
>> Peter: THAT SPECULATION IS
NOT WELCOMED BY SOME LAWMAKERS
IN FLORIDA.
>> TO COME OUT AND TO PLAY YOUR
POLITICS AND TO TALK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SEA LEVEL
RISE IS NOT THE TIME FOR THAT
SHE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
HERSELF.
>> Peter: THE DRARST THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
WHO SAYS HIS STAFF ARE IN TOUCH
WITH LOCAL PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND IN SURFSIDE ISN'T READY
TO WEIGH IN ON A POSSIBLE
CLIMATE CONNECTION YET.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH THE ENERGY
SECRETARY GRANHOLM THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE THE SURFSIDE CONDO'S
COLLAPSE MAY BE A RESULT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION AT THIS
POINT.
>> Peter: PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
STILL TRYING TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE THE WAY THAT HE CAN.
A FEW MINUTES AGO HE SIGNED INTO
LAW A BILL THAT LIMITS METHANE
EMISSIONS.
AT THE END OF THAT BILL-SIGNING
I SHOUTED OUT TO ASK HIM IF HE
HAS ANY KIND OF REACTION TO
DONALD RUMSFELD'S PASSING AND HE
DIDN'T ANSWER.
SO THE PRESIDENT STILL HAS NOT
ADDRESSED THAT ON CAMERA OR OFF
CAMERA.
BRET